[Music]
my favorite moment was probably on the
Batmobile surfing it
yeah yeah with my boy PA down there and
surf from the Batmobile my kids are
watching him like he's got good work
this is like the fanboy in me when I got
to see all the back gadgets
relax don't don't take it from here I
really like when we were all together
first time what everyone has their
costumes on and we're on the set
I was just electrifying this incredible
so crazy to see all of us in these
characters when we were all in our
costumes shooting the fight sequence
don't engage alone again
[Music]
it's a stranger who comes to this
village from the sea he comes in the
winter when people are hungry he brings
fish comes on the King died I was last
night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I just want to say quick thanks to my
cast and crew that's been a great sheet
and Thank You UK
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you do this weekend ina me yeah
nothing very interesting the world
remains in mourning after the death of
the Superman they said the age of heroes
who never come again past him
[Music]
we don't have anymore time
[Music]
something is coming
don't protect issues
no lectures
[Music]
the Kryptonian
[Music]
which made this here
like all the others one misses the day
is where mums biggest concerns were
exploding windup penguins this is crazy
I'll say I think we're all gonna die
each of us in some way is held back
don't engage alone we'll do this
together
it's really cool you guys seem ready to
do battle and stuff never done battle
relax Alfred I'll take it from here do I
know you
Superman was a beacon to the world
to save people you need to see the best
parts of themselves
oh I recognize as well
we don't have to recognize
[Music]
which is have to save it
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough do
you really think oh wow they just they
really just vanish huh oh that's rude
[Music]
he said you'd come
now let's hope you're not too late
[Music]
and